It is time for our final check of the polls
in 2019 we were away all of last year.
This week it's been close to two weeks since
we looked at the polls and when you zoom out
the, the real story to me is basically bad
news for Elizabeth Warren.
Let's take a look right now in an average
of recent polls, it is Biden in first place
with 28 Bernie and second with 19 these are
averages and recent polls and Elizabeth Warren
in third place with 15 still almost doubling
Pete Buddha judge who is in fourth place with
eight.
Now interestingly, and we're showing this
to our video audience, I'll try to describe
it to our radio and podcast audience.
If you were to draw a straight line across
Joe Biden's polling, which is the green line,
you will see that he is very close to where
he was in early July.
He's been up, he's been down since then, but
it's basically an average of being in the
exact same place.
If you do the same with Bernie's polling,
the light blue line, you see that he is roughly
where he was in early may, but if you look
at Elizabeth Warren, you see a much bigger
upswing in the earlier part of this year and
they pretty direct downfalls starting uh,
with her peak in the first week of October
around 27%, almost actually tied for first
place with Joe Biden down to where she is
today at 15, just barely more than half of
the support she wants had.
Now, if you look at the recent individual
polls that make up this average, you see that
Joe Biden is right around the low thirties
with Bernie in the mid to low twenties and
Elizabeth Warren not hitting 20% in any recent
poll.
These are of course, national polls.
If you look at the first primary States who
will be voting very soon.
We have Iowa where Pete Buddha judge according
to the latest polls, which are still not that
new Buddha judge with a slight lead over Bernie
Sanders, Bernie and second place in Iowa,
followed by Joe Biden about a point and a
half behind.
Then you look at New Hampshire and you have
Bernie Sanders, um, in first with Pete booted
judge just behind him and Bernie and Biden
rather further down in third place.
So what's the trajectory here?
What is next in 2020?
The next debate is on January 14th.
So far there are only five candidates who
have qualified.
Those are Joe Biden, uh, Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth
Warren, Pete judge and Amy Klobuchar.
Then, and this is really important, we've
been wondering, is the DNC going to change
the rules to let Mike Michael Bloomberg into
the debates?
Michael Bloomberg is a billionaire who has
been self funding his campaign and not taking
individual contributions.
He very quickly was able to, with the expenditure
of more than a hundred million dollars in
advertising, get himself five, maybe six,
maybe even 7% in one recent poll, which is
quite remarkable given how short of a time
it's been and it shows that at least to some
degree if you've got some name recognition,
you can buy your way in if you spend enough
money into a primary.
We wondered because Bloomberg is not accepting
donations and to get into the debates you
need to meet certain donor thresholds.
Would the DNC consider changing the rules
in order to allow Michael Bloomberg into debates?
Uh, starting with the eighth debate in February,
Tom Perez, the DNC chair says that they are
looking at a different system for determining
who will be allowed into the debates.
The idea that he's using for cover is, listen,
we have had a system in place before anybody
voted.
Once people start voting, maybe we should
have a different system for determining who
does or doesn't get into the debates.
Now I've been saying for weeks now they may
do this and this is how they figured out a
way to maybe have some cover in doing it.
Our friend Dave Weigel recently interviewed
Tom Perez and here's how the conversation
went.
Um, Dave Weigel asked Mike Bloomberg said
he's not going to raise donor money if he
runs, he's going to sell fund his campaign,
which would prevent him from accessing the
stage under the DNCs rules.
Is there any chance that the DNC relaxes the
donor requirement?
If there's someone in the race who's polling
well or winning States but not raising money,
and Tom Perez said, we have our rules in place
for November and December.
Those rules of both the grassroots fundraising
threshold and upholding threshold that used
to be either or.
As you know Dave, and now it's and for November
and December, those are the rules.
We haven't set the rules for after the first
of the new year and that's something that
we're doing right now.
We always set the rules early enough so that
we can give notice to the campaigns.
And Dave Weigel said so it's possible.
It wouldn't be both.
It wouldn't be an and anymore.
Meaning both fundraising and polling and Tom
Perez said, we haven't figured it out.
One thing we will consider is what should
the rules of engagement be after people have
started voting, because right now zero votes
have been cast, the voters haven't spoken.
What should the rules be once the voters have
spoken and we have some actual data from States?
That's the question we're considering right
now, so we now have with debate number eight
in February with the requirements needing
to be met in January.
The opportunity for the DNC to change how
they determine who gets into the debates.
We're going to keep talking about that because
that could be a big deal in terms of, again,
making the scenario one that ultimately leads
to an establishment centrist being the nominee
and we'll talk about
that more in the new year.